it's good to be here I see some
good-looking ladies in the audience
tonight Thank You doesn't man I'm too
analytical with women that's that's my
problem like one time this girl she
texted me very late at night
she wrote come over and then I texted
back is there parking she never wrote
back it's the spot that got away
sometimes women can be rude for no
reason like once I asked a girl out on a
day and she was like I would never date
you in a million years I was like you
could have said a hundred years and that
still would have been devastating what
did you think was gonna happen I was
gonna cryogenically freeze my head and
then four thousand years later be like
what up maybe our oh sure put a window
pick you what what I eat I've realized
dating is essentially guys just
pretending to have way more money than
they really do so what is ladies will
take you to some fancy French restaurant
then we'll take you to go see a play
even after all of that a lot of times a
girl still won't like you at all
which stings as a man because that means
she's not even into the rich version of
you
this is the best possible meat and you
still not into it
imagine if you do how many Chipotle
napkins I hit before you came over so
many a lot of women you like romantic
comedies
you know you'll watch them and be like
how come guys don't act like that in
real life but you don't want that like
you would be super turned off if guys
acted like that in real life like if I
walked up to you and I was like I can't
sleep without you okay the only time
guys act like they're in romantic
comedies is when a bunch of us are
together and one of us gets a text
message with the promise of sex we'll be
hanging out and just out of nowhere like
you know this chick says she's at my
place and wants to rip my pants off
everyone's like what are you doing go
after her
I'm not a big romantic comedy guy last
last movie I saw was um theory of
everything at Stephen Hawking movie you
guys see that yeah it's good it's good
movie it's kind of weird though watching
a movie where you already know what
happens to the person because at the
beginning of the movie he's dancing
around having a good time you're like he
doesn't know
I didn't know that he was married for
like 30 years and yet three kids woman
and then he ended up leaving her for
another woman that's that's pretty
baller when you think about it
to be confined to a wheelchair unable to
talk and still think to yourself I can
do better
[Music]
this [ __ ] is holding me back hey can
you set up the ramp so I can leave you
[Applause]
how did that exchange even go down it's
what I want to know because normally
when couples fight it's this verbal
ping-pong match like screw you no screw
you this woman just had to have waited
forever she's like what you're gonna
leave me and she has to wait for it
you win some you lose some